Transcriptor: Jazziel Noriega
Revisor: Alessandra Mantellini
(Aplausos)
Hola, soy Ezequiel y os voy a confesar
que nunca me ha gustado hablar en público,
ya fuera un público más reducido,
como una clase,
o un público grande
y maravilloso como vosotros,
el caso es que nunca me ha gustado
hablar en público.
Y, pues bueno,
hoy os voy a contar
una experiencia que viví hace un año
que me fui con el colegio
y la verdad es que no sabía
que esta experiencia
me iba a cambiar tanto mi vida.
La experiencia que os voy
a contar hoy para mí
ha sido inolvidable,
ya que gracias a ella he podido potenciar
una cualidad
y una habilidad que nunca sabía
que podía potenciarla de esta manera.
Para todos aquellos
que no sepan qué es el MUN,
es una organi... es un evento
que organiza las Naciones Unidas
para tratar de fomentar el debate
entre las generaciones más jóvenes.
Este evento se realizó en Holanda,
en un colegio de un pueblo pequeño
cerca de Ámsterdam
que se llamaba Farel College,
y de ahí el nombre de FAMUN.
Pues bien, os estaréis preguntando
muchos de vosotros
qué fue esta experiencia,
por qué me ayudó tanto
para potenciar
y dar una mejor versión de mí mismo.
Pues dejadme que os cuente.
Yo siempre he tenido un problema,
que es que no sabía dialogar
con las personas, siempre...
cuando trataba de discutir algo
con una persona acababa enfadado,
acababa cabreado con esa persona
porque no era capaz de dialogar.
Y un día, un día en una clase de inglés,
mi profesor de inglés,
que en paz descanse,
me dijo: “Oye, una experiencia nueva
en Holanda,
que lo organiza las Naciones Unidas”.
Y a mí
me sonó genial, y yo dije:
“Vale, súper divertido, con los amigos,
una experiencia nueva, en otro país,
conocer gente...
Genial.
Pero luego,
a pesar de que me sonase tan bien,
la verdad es que me eché un poco
para atrás porque no sabía...
no sabía qué iba a pasar,
no sabía qué iba a hacer,
y me vi solo,
no me vi con otra gente,
me vi tan solo, iba sin amigos y dije:
“Es que no quiero hacerlo”.
Hablé con mis padres
y mis padres me dijeron:
“Oye, que es una experiencia,
que te vas a llevar a la tumba
con ella, va a ser genial”.
Pero yo me cerré en banda
y hablé con mi profesor,
ese mismo que me planteó la experiencia,
y me dijo: “No te puedes achicar
ante los retos,
porque si vas a estar toda la vida...”
toda la vida viviendo con el miedo,
nunca vas a poder superarlo”.
Y realmente mi miedo era
que yo, pues, no me quería plantar
delante de 100 personas
a hablar sobre un tema.
Pero la verdad es que, cuando llegué allí,
y vi a toda la gente
con sus trajes, sus corbatas,
su “speech” súper preparado
y todo, la verdad es
que me hice como grande,
y a pesar de que solo fueran tres días,
esta experiencia ha conseguido
despertar algo en mí que es el debate.
Yo no sabía que un debate
me iba a gustar tanto
como para intentar dedicar mi vida a ello.
Os pongo en situación.
Este evento se realizaba como si fuera
un congreso normal de las Naciones Unidas
y tú ibas representando diferentes países.
En mi caso, por ejemplo,
yo tuve que representar a Irán
y hacer un...
como un acuerdo con otros países,
como por ejemplo, pues estaba
Estados Unidos, Rusia, Canadá...
España no estaba, pero bueno...
tuve que representar a Irán
y hablar sobre las criptomonedas,
que yo no tenía ni idea
de lo que era una criptomoneda.
Y la verdad es que gracias
a esta experiencia, también,
me he dado cuenta de lo importante que era
conectar con el mundo, conectar con...
con... con lo que está pasando
a día de hoy.
Yo no tenía ni idea
de lo que era la energía nuclear,
ni para qué se utilizaba,
ni cómo se almacenaba.
No tenía ni idea. Y llegué allí
y, gracias a ello, pues,
me pude dar cuenta
de lo importante que...
que es, pues, conectar con el mundo.
Y, pues, la verdad es que esta experiencia
no solo han sido tres días
donde me he ido con amigos
a pasarlo bien y a hacer un “speech”.
Ha sido una experiencia
que me ha ayudado bastante a potenciar
el hablar. Me ha enseñado
los valores de las Naciones Unidas, de...
transmitir, dialogar
con educación, respetando el turno de voz,
respetando los ideales de la otra persona
y discutiendo con educación.
La verdad es que...
para todos aquellos que os estéis pensando
yo llegué allí con muy malas expectativas
y la verdad es que salí de allí pensando
que habían sido los mejores
5 días que he pasado en mi vida.
Y, a pesar
de que os haya dicho antes que...
nunca me ha gustado hablar en público,
pues al final aquí estoy.
Dando la chapa
con toda esta experiencia y cómo he podido
dar una mejor versión de mí mismo.
Muchas gracias por vuestra atención.
Espero que os haya gustado.
(Aplausos)